former President Obama's defense
secretary ash Carter is offering a new
inside look at the Pentagon one of the
world's largest and most complex
organizations it comes at a time of
course of rising tensions between the US
and other nations iran's Foreign
Minister said this morning that the u.s.
cannot expect to say stay safe that's
his words after launching what he called
an economic war against Iran and just
last week this Russian warship came
within feet of crashing into the USS
Chancellorsville in the Philippine Sea
Carter tells the story of the Pentagon
and how it deals with security threats
in his new book inside the five sided
box lessons from a lifetime of
leadership in the Pentagon and ash
Carter joins us first on CTM secretary
good morning good to be here so there's
a lot to get to in the book and also in
the wider world but I wanted to start
with something that has the potential to
color everything that you tell us today
and that's two years ago a little bit
more you said that you are outside of
politics you declined to comment on
President Trump and the Trump
administration in this book you do
comment and you comment strongly you say
the president is not someone you would
work for you say his administration is
characterized by offensive racist
divisive language and that you would
fire an officer for it what changed
between you being outside of politics
and today and are you worried that
people like yourself commenting wading
in in this way could politicize
something like the Department of Defense
it's not it's not politics it's personal
conduct in the book I'm talking about
what the way the public servants in my
all the years I worked for presidents of
both parties for a 30-7 in in Pentagon's
for over thirty seven years and I used
to tell officers and soldiers that they
needed to behave themselves that part of
the profession of arms was honor and
trust and it's not just the president
it's the the kind of behavior and
personal conduct that you see everywhere
in Washington today is not the kind of
thing as the book said that we tolerated
in the military the press I fired be
fired my fired people for doing that and
and my subordinates fired people for for
even less so we held held
i standards and I think that's important
on the question of whether to work for
president rubber now this is purely
hypothetical I'm gonna yeah you also
point out who you weren't asked to work
for him the point I was making the book
was I was giving advice to future office
holders and say and I was saying that in
order your first duty as a cabinet
secretary is to serve the President to
help him and all I was saying there with
respect to President Trump is I wouldn't
know how to help him because he doesn't
seem to take the advice of his cabinet
secretaries and so I couldn't take a job
knowing that I I what would I know and
what I brought to the job I wouldn't be
able to apply to help him we need to
help him succeed he's the president
United States that's not waiting in
apology know how to these comments are
not waiting into politics I'm just I was
talking about the Pentagon and giving
advice to got your leaders in the
management about how to behave
themselves and whether it when they're
offered a job to say yes or not and I
was saying you only say yes if you
believe that you can be make a
difference yeah we spent 35 years in the
Defense Department what do you see is
the most urgent threat facing this
country right now
well we unfortunately don't have one we
have China Russia Iran North Korea
terrorism and I tell you it's not a
place but I think the I'm confident in
our plans and our capabilities with
respect to all five of those today I I
have great confidence in them the future
is more concerning to me it's a
competitive world all five of those are
potential opponents are focused on us
and we have to deal with all five of
them and it's a fast technology moves in
technology and so we need to make sure
we stay competitive because being the
best which we are isn't a birthright you
got to keep earning it but you're
concerned about that though ash Carter
you say in the book the US military
needs to regain the competitive edge you
just slipped away a little bit from us
yeah we used to have the Soviet Union as
a sort of benchmark for ourselves to
compete against and then the Cold War
ended and there was
decade when Russia was weak China was
weak and then we were we have been
focusing and I focused on them and I
don't know apologies for that Iraq
Afghanistan counter insurgency
countering terrorism I was all in for
those when I was in the defense you have
to be smart for the future it's it's
massive you point out the Defense
Department employs more men and women
than Amazon McDonald's FedEx Target
General Electric conducts more research
than Apple Google and Microsoft you said
combined that's a very good point to
make you said this is not a memoir you
just wanted people to know how big it is
and that you felt uniquely qualified to
do this job because you worked in all
department it just turns out I first
walked into the Department of Defense in
1981 Caspar Weinberger the secretary
defense Ronald Reagan was the president
United States and I walked out that just
before the inauguration in 2017 and so
I've seen a lot and it turns out I've
been in every corner of the place and so
if you want to you're one of these
people who wants to get behind the sort
of mystery of what is the Pentagon and
how does it work
how do you buy fighter jets how do you
hire and fire people on basis of conduct
how do you conduct Wars what's the how
do you manage the world's largest
enterprise you describe Joe Biden as an
old friend in the books he's not running
for president do you think that old
friend is the strongest candidate in
your field that that is politics because
we used to my wife lived in Baltimore
and I used to ride the train all the
time from Washington to Baltimore and
that's i9 as a lovely man very nice man
but I do I'm not in politics I've never
been in politics I'm not going to call
they say otherwise
yes yes I agree with that we can say
that today you're wearing a suit and a
tie you tell a great story when you
landed in the Middle East and somebody
said you what no no tie today when you
were meeting the judge my very first
mine always wears a tie and he saw a
picture because you pictures taken all
the time
and I got off the plane in the clothes I
had worn on the plane and we're going to
hotel and I was gonna change into a suit
and right away he wrote to me and said
no suit and the bulb went off you always
need to look proper and it's it's
another part of behavior yeah look like
someone's mom is watching I was very
good in the desert got into hundreds of
hands looking just like this and
sweating like a wheel of cheese but why
did I do that that's a good graphic of
wheel of cheese thank you thank you so
much